in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Darrell
and Sally are with us from South
Carolina hey guys how are you well how
are you
and we deserve I hear you man thanks for
visiting how can I help today well I had
a question we are debt free yeah you're
programming you and we're having trouble
staying on track for becoming
millionaires redic free and we want to
be able to say save and give okay so um
you're not investing we are we have our
15 percent in our 401ks I work part-time
mm-hmm now to take care of our 15 year
old okay all right and Darrell you're
still working full time when you retire
okay all right and so how are you having
trouble staying on track what do you
just spending money or what do you mean
budget don't have any payments sticking
to the budget and don't know if it's
possible for us to become millionaires
at this stage I'm a little older 58
mm-hmm 55 okay what's your household
income about fifty thousand okay
fifty-five and how much do you have
saved in cash that equity about two
sixteen okay mm-hmm okay yeah you're on
your way you're gonna be fine 216 in
your 401k combination 401k and Roth are
a week that's invested like we teach and
good growth stock mutual funds it should
double about every seven years so that
means when you're 65 that should be
worth about 400 and then when you're 72
if you don't have anything to it and
when you're 72 that'd be worth about 800
and your house of course is going up in
value during that time that we're
talking about as well so I predict if
you don't do anything you'll probably be
millionaires by the time you're 70 if we
continue to work it know if you just let
the money that's in there continue to
sit there and grow and you get your hand
your house is paid off and you own it
right yes that's it worth
roughly between 150-160 some yeah I mean
so basically you out of a million you've
currently got about 380 or so okay
yes something like that so you're about
a third of the way there
and if you just consider that's gonna
double if you don't do anything else
every seven years okay so it'll double
once from 350 to seven and double again
from seven to 1.5 by the time you're 72
give or take so you're fine but if you
want to do more you can do more so and I
would I would do more I would invest
some more and you got the 15% of your
income going in so that's another 7,500
a year on top of what we're talking
about continuing to go into the 401 K if
you want to crank that up a little bit
now that the house is paid for you can
you can max that out put the motion that
they allow you to put in and max out a
couple of Roth IRAs the thing I have
found is if I can do stuff that is kind
of on autopilot and doesn't require my
force of will to create discipline it
helps me and so I just put all kinds of
stuff just drafting on my checking
account going straight into investments
and then I don't think about it I just
run the house then whatever is left in
there and it's like you know that money
went over there that mutual fund and
into those retirement accounts and and
then I just make it on you know I do the
budget on whatever is left over that
helps me because it's kind of on
autopilot the second thing you should do
is you need to make sure that you're
setting some milestones that when you
hit a certain point on different things
that you do something to celebrate
you guys aren't celebrating you're not
spending the money on you know and you
need to do some of that and you need to
go on a cruise or whatever you know
whatever the thing is you've always
wanted to do you always wanted to buy
one of those old cars or you wanted to I
don't care what it is but you need to go
spend a little bit of money on you once
you hit some of these marks because
otherwise it just becomes a pure grind
and it's living like no one else so that
later you can live like no one else
and give like no one else and then
that's the last thing make sure that
your giving is done and it's done in a
personal enough way that you see the
people's lives changed it's good to give
sometimes to an institution to your
church and those kinds of things we do
and and I do too but I also want to do
something occasionally where I just see
somebody's life changed and we try to do
that direct type thing and that keeps
you fired up too because that shows you
the power of money when you've got it
and it's in the hands of a generous
person but if it just goes in the
line-item somewhere off in some company
or some nonprofit off in the distance
you don't feel it you see what I'm
saying yes sorry
that'll jazz you spend little money on
you I'll jazz you when you hit some of
these milestones and and then I will
just go ahead and max out your 401ks and
your Roth IRAs right now do all of that
and sit down do that does that help you
yes it does Mason thanks for coming by
it's an honor to meet you too appreciate
you hanging out with us